one Championship goes we believe in
mixed martial arts we believe in martial
arts in general so Francis will have an
opportunity to a fight for World
Championship in mixed martial arts and B
we're open to him fighting boxing he box
first that was his caveat with UFC well
I want to box first and then fight new
scene you see when absolutely not when
Championship said cool we'll let you do
that we'll be part of that we'll be part
of the marking of that we'll do all that
for you now what's he gonna do it's not
good man and I don't know who needs to
get in Frontier nobody needs you big
special arts across the board box and
cross board will be just fine nobody's
bigger than the game nobody nobody the
closest person we've ever had that was
bigger than the game is Conor McGregor
he has some a little more leverage in
Francis right so for France it's like I
don't know who you're listening to man
but this is not going well this has been
a disaster